c'est un visage très connu des Russes à
la bukacheva est probablement la plus
grande chanteuse de variété qui est
connue le pays depuis l'époque
soviétique mais ces derniers jours elle
s'est plutôt illustrée en s'opposant
publiquement à la guerre en Ukraine sur
Instagram où elle compte des millions
d'abonnés la star a pris la défense de
son époux le comédien Maxime gelquin qui
figure désormais sur la liste des agents
de l'étranger l'acteur en exil a
toujours ouvertement critiqué la
campagne militaire russe je vous demande
de me classer parmi les agents de
l'étranger de mon cher pays car je suis
solidaire avec mon mari mon époux défend
la liberté d'expression en Russie et la
fin de la mort de nos garçons pour des
objectifs illusoirs
russes quitter son pays juste après le
début de l'offensive le 24 février
dernier c'est l'une des rares
personnalités russes à avoir
publiquement pris position sur le sujet
car les règles sont claires
toute critique de ce que le Kremlin
appelle l'opération militaire spéciale
et prohibée mais malgré le risque de se
voir infliger une amende ou d'être
incarcéré la parole se libère peu à peu
dans le pays depuis lundi dernier une
pétition signée par des dizaines des lus
locaux russes appelant à la démission de
Vladimir Poutine fait beaucoup de bruit
nous vous demandons de libérer le poste
que vous occupez car vos opinions et
votre modèle de gouvernance sont
désespérément dépassés et sont un frein
au développement de la Russie et de son
potentiel humain le chef du parti
communiste a même appelé à une
mobilisation mardi dernier et exige que
le terme de guerre soit désormais
utilisé pour parler de l'invasion russe
en Ukraine